hi this is Ashley Benson with et style  and I'm going to share with you my kit  essentials traveling it's very important  I have to always have a body wash that I  like funny enough no put I just started  using the l a foaming whip body wash  it's incredible I use it this morning in  my shower it feels like shaving cream  but then it turns to foam and it's  really nice and it leaves me feeling  really great I always have coconut oil  just to keep my face moisturize because  my face is dry I never really knew how  to do my own makeup I kind of recently  just learned to be honest being on set  I've always related that to makeup  because I don't really wear much outside  of work no no no that's a mistake a good  concealer a nice little glow bronzer  maybe a little chapstick eyebrow gel  100% is that five things and perfume  [Music]